hello everyone uh welcome to pi data
global 2021
uh i am conrad one of the co-chairs for
pi data global
uh we're very happy today to welcome
chung suan wang
uh he is uh
uh coming here today to talk to us about
fugue sequel
um he was previously uh at a cruise and
lyft and he's currently uh working in a
startup so thank you chung swan please
take it away
sure
hi everyone um my name is transhuen
so
hello everyone my name is joshua and
today i'm going to talk about phuket
circle
and abstraction
a physical a a
an abstract interface for distributed
computing please feel free to ask any
question in the chat the create the
create or field is also in the channel
so if i didn't don't say the questions
you can answer as well
so firstly let's have an overview of
field
there are there are different
different computing frameworks
in the industry like uh spark dusk
pandas and on gpu its rapids and the
blazing circle
and each wizard each has a different
slightly different interfaces fuga is a
is an abstraction layer unifying the
computation on top of figure we already
have fuel circle validation and tune
today's topic is the fuel circle
let's talk about taco about a few circle
if you ever use the circle in your
python workflow you will see this common
pattern you write a blog or python code
saying invoke circle and do something
and get the data frame back and then
repeat
this code is very convoluted by
switching between python and the circle
this seems inevitable because python is
the dominated language and the circle is
not designed to support multiple tasks
physical solves this problem by adding
extra intuitive syntax to the standard
circle so you can easily describe your
entity and workflow
using circle as the dominated language
in addition you can write the same
simple python function as it as
extensions that can be directly invoked
by circle commonly you will see your
code that becomes significantly shorter
with much better readability i also want
to mention that physique circle can use
a circle pleasing circle in a spar
circle as the backhand it can it can
also run with but and and of course it
can long it can also run without any of
them that's why [ __ ] circle is very unit
testable
now let's take a look
of an example we want to compute the
media of column d over panda data data
frame and then get the difference of hd
and the media it's quite simple to
express in pandas but not
easily at all in circle so we just write
a also we write such a function
in this computing example we will use
fugue on dusk and that's dust circle we
have two data frames as input which is
the df1 and the ds2 we want to we want
to draw them get the product over b and
the c
as the column d
we can use a circle here and then we
want to do two things one is to compute
a different difference from media over
for each
of for each group another is to take the
smallest angles from each group sorted
by b and c on the left hand uh it's the
hallway do it using dusk and the dark
circle and we have to write another
first end
first end to do the second thing now
let's take a look at
how to express things logically in
phuket circle we only need a as we can
see we only need a
a single single block of circle code
here we defend and ascend
and then uh ascend junk logic
uh in a way like python and uh and the
true computer media div we can also
directly invoke the media gif function
and we don't have to care about the
metadata which is a specific specific
thing and for dusk and the two gather
first and loose in
india in a group we don't even need to
implement anything we have the
ticker keyword to handle that actually
ticker can be significantly faster than
the python approach in certain execution
engines
also please pay attention to the engine
compute2 is no longer
only for dusk it can run on qdf and the
blazing it can run on spark and it can
run without any of them that's how you
do unit test
you also have a lot of
flexibility on the input the f1 and the
df2 can be dependent data frames dusk
difference or cooldown
and the engine can be combination of
dust energy plus blazing circle energy
so your circle will execute is good as
freezing circle and the rest will use
use dust too long distributedly you will
see more details example in the
following demo where we will use a free
circle on spark
okay it's demo time so so in this demo
we will
so in this in this demo we will i will
show how few
how [ __ ] circle makes circle as the
first class citizen for data pipeline
and the data process
i will use two examples to demonstrate
the basic feature of fuel circle
so uh so just a reminder there is spark
logic in the demo
it's but it's only for comparison it's
not necessary to understand the spark
circle here
so let's see take a look at the first
example so you are processing a data
frame and here is a business requirement
so the data framework has four columns a
b c d and the types are all string
and uh the business logic is
for any given rule if the number of now
no no value is smaller than two we drop
the row otherwise we concatenate the
null columns in order are put in in
another column called e and also in the
in the same time we also keep the
original columns
so firstly let's generate some test data
so you you don't need to care about the
logic to generate the tester data so
let's just take a look at the test data
so as you can see there is abcd columns
and also they are all a string and only
contain x y z but also notice that there
is some columns it has now value
okay so let's see how we can use a fuel
circle to do simple data exploration
so so as you can see we we are given a
notebook magic
called f circle so it indicated in this
in this cell we will use the field
circle
so so let's see we want to say we want
to filter out all the rules where the
value of column column a is either x or
y so it's it's pretty easy to express in
circle so let's do it
as you can see the result only contains
x y
for column a
so so uh so if uh so the default
backhand over fuel circle is pandas so
uh so uh
so that's the reason so so so the output
will be panda data data frames but the
water but the fuel circle is not only
about pandas it can it also can run any
excuse engines we like so if we want to
along the along the same logic in spark
we just need to specify the spark at the
end
and the end of the [ __ ] circle magic
and the same lord and the way with the
same logic we can we can definitely can
give the same results
yep let's see so the results is actually
they are the same
so so uh as as we can we we also support
multiple execution engines this is spark
and also like uh we can also log on task
okay and you may notice that one way
wrong with the spark but the sample
sample uh
the type of sample is actually panda
data frames how do we do the conversion
uh so you don't need to fulfill the
circle you don't need to worry about
that uh circle do the do the other o2
conversion for you so no matter the
sample data is a panda data frame or
spark different or task different it'll
it will always works
okay so let's go into the business logic
so you may uh you may think you need to
express the business logic in circle you
may find that it's quite it's quite hard
to do that but for native uh battlefield
by using python it's very easy to to
write so here is the function and i
think it's it's almost the most
intuitive way and easier easiest to
easiest tool to read so we we shoot the
data frame as the iterable of list of
values
and of course the output is another data
frame so it's also the same type as the
input so inside for each row uh in the
data frame we first get all the non-null
values and if the nano value is a bigger
or equals to
we generate we yield the load and the
plus the concatenate of all the non-null
values
uh as the new uh as the new uh you know
as the new columns
but because it's very it's it's playing
python and so it's very unique testable
so let's firstly we can write a simple
test to do that
as you can see the last rules will be
omitted because there'll be too many uh
nouns and for the first three rules it
will output another column as the
concatenation of
nominal columns in that
okay so you may wondering now let's run
it
like uh now we want to make make it
scalable so we want to make it
uh distribute
so let's say let's first say how can we
run it all or using a little pi spark
so because a pi spark always take a
spark data frame as the input so so we
need to firstly convert the sample which
is the pendant data frame to spark a
data frame and in order to
use the circle the most intuitive
expression in circle to to do the
filtering we first need to register a
data frame into a table so we call those
uh users create or replace temper view
to do that then we apply the
uh applied uh the circle here uh
then we will say we need to use the map
partition function functions
on spark rdd
a partitioning function is a very
powerful function but it only takes
the iterable of law
as the input as the input type and this
rule is a execution
aware which is only available in pi
spark so in order to use the
concatenated function we we defend we
first need to write this wrapper
function and inside the left function we
needed to uh create a and convert
function uh in order to generate the
iterable of lists of values which in
here is a b say d and then apply the
concat okay finally we you know we use
the cancer function here but uh at last
we still want to uh uh we want to do
group by e column and order by the
counts of
over the number in e column so it's also
very into very easy and intuitive in uh
to express in circle but uh but uh in
order to to do that we still
we still need to
use the create all replace tamper view
to register result data frame into a
table result
so so you may say so the same pattern
happens again so here is the python code
and invoke a circle and another python
code
and invoke a circle again
so it's it's a it has a lot of
borderplate encoder need to write but
firstly let's run it
so it uh produces some values here
let's see now let's say how can we uh to
produce derivative infused circle
so so in fluke circle we uh we
introduced a transform a keyword a
transform keyword that can use a
python function to do the transform
formation because a concat is very hard
to express the in uh you know in uh in
standard circle so we have we have
little help from pencil python function
so so basically we first select you to
do the filtering which is very easy to
express in circle then also use the
concatenated function which is very easy
to express in python and the lastly it's
also it's also a very easy to express in
circle uh uh to do the grouping and
order by lastly we print
so as you can see we give the exactly
the same result as the native python
passback code and of course we can use
different execution engines
just by using you know uh for example
here using spark we also give the same
results
and also this sample is you know it's a
panda data frame and uh
and even even though we use spark it
also can run because we do the
automatic conversion for you
okay so uh so uh business requirements
always change so uh so here is the
business requirement change so uh so for
this time the input data no longer have
column d other things i remain unchanged
let's prepare the data
okay there is no column d here right uh
so let's see uh if the original pi spark
code can work
so so let's run it so you will see it is
a slowest exception because the column d
is already gone in the original data so
this means the original level function
we will write no longer works with the
uh the updated data so because there is
no column d right
so in order to make it work we need to
create another new wrapper to
create another new level 2 function uh
basically to omit the load id here and
apply the same logic
and of course we need to we always need
to
specify the uh output schema explicitly
okay so let's say uh
let's say how we do it in future circle
you may aware we didn't change any code
in this bug other than the input data
this is it because
in fluke circle we always support the
star the world card uh schemer it means
uh
when we do the transform we use the
previous we use the previous output data
schema which
if we use a stack here it means we just
just
put the already the importer uh data
schema here and plus a new column so
it's because and also because the concat
function it only takes uh iterable of
this value it doesn't uh we are any of
the schema so so the so so that's the
reason
with these two benefits we don't need to
change any data other than the input
data
yeah so it works as well so
okay so let's go to a second example in
this example i want
i will
i will show how how to use a free circle
to do a basic machine learning so we
have
a pair of trim and a tester data set
with a partition key on category
we want to trim a logistical regression
model on training set and uh and the
dual distributors inference on the test
set if the test set is very bad
so uh of course let's
prepare some uh training data in the
test data
and uh let's take a look of the training
data so we have the abcde as a future
volume and also the y is the ground
choice and yeah basically the target
value and the category is the partition
key and the train is you know it's for
for training data it's always true
otherwise for test data it's false
okay so so let's see how we can
do it in in local machine so here is
because we already have the have the
training data and uh we know abcd is the
future data and the training y trin y is
the target value so we can easily train
our logistic regression model here and
the dump into our local storage
and for the prediction function it's
also very easy we just load the model
from the local machine and
use the predictor function applied on
the
tester data with the feature columns
abcde and generator pride and also
append the private column to the
original tester data
okay so and of course because it's very
very easy to to write let's write a test
for it and we see uh the prediction here
okay so so a rectangle let's say when
the test data frame becomes super big so
we needed to
apply
this jupiter way to do that distributed
influence
so let's see how we do it in uh playing
pi spark code
so as usual we needed to convert the
original panda data frame to spark data
frame
and uh for this two lens it's basically
we want to define the output
uh the the schema of output data frame
so basically we take all the all the
original uh columns from the tesla data
and append the prior the column as the
prediction
as uh you you can see here we no longer
use the map application function uh
again uh because and here we use the map
in uh
pandas this is because the prediction
function takes the panda data frame and
the easiest way to do uh to apply the
prediction function is to treat it as a
panda udf so
so in all but in order to do to use
panda udf we needed to let another uh
predict wrapper because uh because the
vaping pandas only takes
iterator over panda data
data free
premiums and also because we need to uh
you know use the user parameter uh in
the in the predator in the predictive
function we need to defend the lambda
here and this schema is the you know the
the schema we just defined with predict
and then lastly we want to calculate the
precision which is the summation of true
positive and the summation of all the
true values
so firstly let's learn it
but you can say we also need to write
some body plate code
for example the wrapper
okay so uh so so the precision is 73
percent
so let's see how we can do in quick
circle
uh actually it doesn't
it actually it only needs three lines of
code so basically we uh transform
a transform the test data set by using
the predictive function we just defended
here and uh we also can pass in the
parameters
uh
and also and we don't need to write the
two lines to uh to specify the schema
because we we have one cut and uh we
just append another print a column in
integer at the end
and then and for the uh playstation
calculation it's also very easy to
express in
uh you know a
uh in in circle so
so we only need a three lens
so we but we also get the same result as
the pi digital pi start code
okay so this data scientists always need
to experiment on different uh on
different ideas so this time we we may
think
uh we basically if we can partition the
training data by category first and then
for each category we we train a
different model then we do the influence
uh assembling uh let's see if we can
improve the presentation so firstly
let's define two uh two functions one is
the trim function basically use the uh
logistic regression
model
and to train on the abcde
feature columns and and uh also we dump
we save the binary
over the model into model column and for
the for the
prediction because uh the data is
already partitioned by the category uh
and they are should be so there should
be only only one model so we do a
validation here and then we load the
binary model into into our object and
then do the prediction on the test
tester data
okay so so because of the partitioning
logic it's almost very hard to write in
python and and the standard circle but
how how do we do
in fuel circle
uh it's it's pretty easy
as you can see we just transform with
the training data and the pre partition
on the category then use the trin
trinket function we defended here uh
uh to train on each each different
category and also generate the
generator output with schema category
and the model binary which matched these
two outputs here
and therefore for the inference
it's also very easy because we provide
the same keywords here we can zip the
models and the data since the model has
the category as a production key and the
data also has a
category as a partition key we can just
receive them together and the figure
circle will automatically help you to do
the zip then we transform the save the
data using the prediction function
with defender in in python
uh and the output of the data frame you
may notice that the prediction function
is actually has more columns but a way
by the but here we only care about the y
column predict predicted column and the
string and training column
at last we used you know
very easy to express uh circle to to do
the to calculate the precision because
the uh because the the inference way we
train on the we influence all the whole
data so it has both training data that
test the data so
so we need a group back here so uh so
this is actually the from the in the
precision on the test data so we say
it's 88 it's much better than the
73 percent
okay
so so uh right now uh as the data center
down the experimentation on on small
data center we want to production like
uh production on a large data set uh
fugus figure also can use it we just
need to put the uh you know the circle
into our into a variable and uh import
the figure f circle flow figure sequel
call
and uh apply it with the circle and also
we can pass in some parameters
uh in this case is the
uh is the data and we can run on uh
different execution engines in this case
is barcelona
uh at the last way i also mentioned that
we also have
[Music]
we also have
a functional interface so we will also
have function interface in parallel with
the fuel circuit
uh a chance one just uh just a quick
thing uh you have five minutes left so
in case you want to do more of a q a uh
uh you know quickly wrap up and do that
uh otherwise also just feel free to just
uh you know do the whole thing without a
q a thanks
sure
uh uh i'll move for finish so
so we have we also have the functional
interface
uh
in parallel with the circle so if you're
more preferred functional interface so
you can use the function interface here
okay let's go back to a slide and then
wrap up
so what's the motivation of creating the
fuse project in the past
we created our own computing logic to
long locally use it using simple python
in the circle but in order to scale out
we have to use certain distributed
computing engine
in order to use a certain engine we
normally have to adopt their apis and
interfaces making our core logic
convoluted and hard to maintain
so instead of learning and adapting to
certain frameworks how about create
create a abs abstraction layer that's
the motivation of fugue
it's it's to it's to hide the complexity
and the inconsistency of different
computing frameworks and provide a
unified approach to do distributed
uh computing and machine learning with
this design since the core logic is
written in simple ways they are already
easy to unit test
plus
plus figure can let you use local
execution engine and the mock data frame
to long or data pipeline and trend
without the spark and the dusk
so it's very iterative
uh
at the last and because the
fugu is the perform agnostic so it
becomes uh very
migratable uh you can uh uh so so your
call logic can the figure level code
can run on spark dusk blazing without
any code change
okay all the packages i talked about
today are open source for field
core and the free circle please install
the field package and for gpu and the
blazing support please install fuel
blazing
thank you
oh i saw the question from
how performance of
field handle extreme large import values
so so because fug is a execution engine
exhaust checkers so if you uh if you
write your own logic in your local
machines then it it can be easily a
scale out that you are distributed and
fashion so
it's
so i think it's the performance is very
good
um okay uh if we don't have more
questions uh we're gonna have to uh get
ready for this talk uh thank you a lot
trixman
thank you thank you for your time thank
you thank you guys